Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
It’s Marvel Tuesday and there is a bunch
of awesome stuff happening.
This video will be an big update on all the
things we know about the Ant-Man movie coming
next year and tonight I’ll be doing a breakdown
of the Marvel Special.
They’ll be some new footage from the set
of Avengers 2.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ve bookmarked Tuesdays as Marvel days
just because I’m already doing videos for
SHIELD.
If there’s any movie you want me to do a
video for just write your suggestion in the
comments.
So here’s 5 major things you need to know
about Ant-Man
Number 5 - Elephant In The Room.
There’s one tiny, super major detail they
changed about the characters.
In the comics Hank Pym the first Ant-Man creates
Ultron, the Avengers most infamous villain.
But because of the way Marvel’s movies have
unfolded and because they want all the stories
to integrate, they had to change that.
I covered Ultron’s new origin in the Avengers
2 video I did last week, but the Ant-Man movie
if it does feature Ultron, will focus mostly
on a different Ant-Man, the Scott Lang version
of the character.
Quick side note, regardless of the plot of
Avengers 2, I am so hoping there’s an Ultron
cameo in Ant-Man.
It would be blasphemous if there weren’t.
Number 4 - The movie will feature Hank Pym,
played by Michael Douglas, but the main character
is really Scott Lang, the second Ant-Man.
If you’re not familiar with the comics,
Scott Lang’s run as the character was less
of a dark angsty story and more of a fun series
of adventures.
Hank Pym was like a version of Tony Stark,
genius inventor who develops the Ant-Man suit.
Scott Lang was actually a criminal who stole
the Ant-Man suit to save his daughter.
Over time Hank Pym then kind of became an
Obi-Wan Kenobi to him and helped him become
a real hero.
It will also star Michael Pena and Patrick
Wilson.
We don’t know who there charcters will be
and we don’t know if The Wasp, Janet Van
Dyne’s character will be featured.
But I would at least expect her to be referenced.
Rashida Jones is rumored to be in talks, so
she would be a good candidate for The Wasp.
There is a third version of Ant-Man in the
comics, Eric O’Grady, but he probably won’t
be part of the story.
It’s really just going to be Paul Rudd and
super hero jedi master Michael Douglas.
Number 3 - The movie is the beginning of Phase
3, coming just 3 months after Avengers 2.
So they will probably address some of the
things that happen during that movie.
The Avengers will probably defeat but not
kill Ultron and the infinity gems storyline
will develop more.
Plus there’s the continuing Presence of
Coulson and SHIELD.
I’d say Nick Fury too, but all of the teasers
for Captain America make it seem like he dies.
I think it would be foolish to assume that
he will, if they brought Coulson back from
the dead.
They can bring Fury back too.
That being said Phase 3 will be the era of
‘quote unqote’ miracles.
Meaning mutant abilities and more fantastical
stories.
Like Magic.
It will also feature a changing Avengers roster.
Different types of villains, like Ultron and
Thanos, require different types of super heroes.
Number 2 - The movie is directed by Edgar
Wright of Cornetto Trilogy Fame.
If you haven’t seen any of his other movies,
get on it.
They’re all amazing.
He’s mostly famous for Shaun of the Dead,
Hot Fuzz and now World’s End.
But he’s also done a ton of other awesome
stuff.
And on top of that, he has a blog that he
posts awesome stuff to on a regular basis.
One of the things I love about Marvel directors
like Edgar Wright and James Gunn who did Guardians,
is that they’re highly engaged with the
fandom.
It’s like when I do Q&A videos and include
your comments or do videos based on your suggestions.
It’s just makes things so much more fun
when you know the creative person behind all
this is listening to you and cares about what
you think.
and number 1 - Remember how I just said the
Avengers roster will be changing.
Well in the comics, under the tutelage of
Obi-Wan Hank Pym, Scott Lang becomes part
of the Avengers.
You can see where this is going.
It’s going to be like the first Iron Man
movie, when Nick Fury and Coulson approached
Tony Stark.
Avengers 3 is a long way off, but it’s likely
then that Paul Rudd will be one of the second
tier Avengers in that movie, like Black Widow
and Hawkeye.
We don’t know what parts of the comics they’re
including in the story, but if you want to
read the comics with Scott Lang’s run as
Ant-Man start with Avengers number 181.
He didn’t become Ant-Man until Marvel Premiere
number 47.
But both those are from 1979, so this was
a long time ago.
The cool thing that Marvel does though is
discount the comics associated with movies
that are coming up.
So like right now, there’s a big discount
on Comixology for Captain America comic books.
Quick Bonus point - A big part of Scott Lang’s
run as the character was Pym Particles, because
Star Wars ran afoul of midichlorians I think
Marvel might side-step the issue.
But a core part of Hank Pym’s character
is that he’s mentally unstable as a result
of repeated exposure to Pym Particles.
I’ll be interested to see how Michael Douglas
portrays this on screen.
I always thought of Pym as a crazier version
of Tony Stark.
Which kind of explains how he could create
Ultron.
But since the movies are changing all that,
they might change Pym’s personality a little
too.
So now it’s your turn, what are you hoping
to see in Ant-Man and do you think they’ll
have any Ultron easter eggs?
Marvel has become famous for easter eggs and
post credits scenes.
Remember the next movie after Ant-Man is Captain
America 3.
So SHIELD is definitely going to be featured
at the end of this movie.
So in related news, Avengers 2 tonight.
Breakdown coming.
I’ll be posting that right after it airs.
Click here to get that video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
the video.
And click here to learn more about Avengers
2.
Thanks so much for watching, see you guys
tonight.
High Fives!